we've got a fox news alert for you a
shooting has occurred at YouTube it's
California headquarters the shooter
apparently is a woman Fox's Claudia
Cohen is standing by with new
information on what happened Claudia yes
and we just got a press update from the
police chief here in San Bruno good
evening Tucker just a horrific scene
here today at the headquarters of
YouTube after a shooter opened fire
inside the facility during the lunch
hour this incident left four victims
injured they are now being treated at
local hospitals police say they also
found a woman they suspect was the
shooter dead of a self-inflicted gunshot
wound
officers just announcing that they have
completed their intensive search of this
massive facility and don't think there
are any other suspects or victims police
say they have recovered a handgun now
it's possible this may have been the
result of a domestic dispute police have
not yet confirmed that but witnesses say
they saw a woman take aim at a man who
may have been her boyfriend before
turning the gun on herself now the names
of the suspected shooter and the victims
have not yet been released we understand
one man is in critical condition but it
is unclear whether he was the intended
target Tucker this investigation is just
now getting underway but obviously a
very tragic and a very scary day here in
San Bruno at YouTube headquarters back
to you horrifying Claudia thank you FEMA
shooters do exist but they are much
rarer than male shooters what do we know
about the profile of the suspect in this
case who apparently has died sheshank
ins is a former FBI special agent he
joins us tonight
Chad how often have you seen something
like this in the course of your career
well Tucker it's an anomaly I mean
typically when you see especially a
single active shooter the overwhelming
statistic is that it will be a male so
we did have this San Bernardino
terrorist attack however that was a
husband-wife team so typically you don't
see a female in an active shooter role
so the suggestion at this hour and these
things are dynamic and we may know
something very different soon but that
this was what police are describing is a
domestic incident what exactly does that
mean well it means most likely workplace
violence or some type of a relationship
gone awry in which she decided to attack
at the workplace but really for the
viewers at home we need to really hone
in that this can happen anywhere and we
as American citizens need to be prepared
for this type of atrocious act to happen
and have a mental plan set forth that's
the day in which we live we cannot rely
upon law enforcement or security
personnel for our safety unfortunately
well that's certainly the lesson of
recent shootings for sure this took
place at YouTube part of Google one of
the biggest companies in the world how
hard would it be to get a firearm into
building like that well if the
individual knew the security protocols
already in place we've already heard
that there was security at this facility
but you can't predict the unpreventable
you are the unpredictable you can only
plan for so if a person has a will
they'll find a way to to conduct this
that's why we need to really stress that
the individual citizens need to have a
plan to to go to in these horrific
events
so the initial accounts of what happened
in the building suggested that there
might have been an ideological or
religious motivation I obviously can't
endorse that don't know if that's true
do we know any more about that at this
time I have not heard a motive being
given by the local law enforcement
I'm sure FBI is helping in the
investigation witness interviews things
of that nature
but I have not heard what the the motive
was behind this perpetrated a attack
yeah well there's a lot we don't know
but we'll continue to follow this story
as the develop said thank you thanks
Tucker